gang-rape text messages bar fights oh my
as the new accusations roll in by the
day new polls are coming out too and
they don't look great for Democrats the
race in Montana has come to a dead heat
and Heidi Heitkamp and Claire McCaskill
and Joe Donnelly in North Dakota and
Missouri and Indiana are now trailing
behind their Republican challengers so
Schumer faces a choice
keep fighting Cavanaugh or try to win
the Senate we will examine where this is
headed then the ACLU becomes a jo ke
snoot diggity Doo dog calls Kanye West
and Uncle Tom for thinking and
Republicans give Woodrow Wilson a stroke
on this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Oh is there so much to get to today so
many super credible new accusations
SuperDuper serious and actually some
terrific news from all of the polls for
Republicans and for judge Cavanaugh
before we get to that let me feed you
let me feed you I brought you into my
boudoir come into my kitchen now I've
got to talk about blue apron you know
how much I love blue apron blue apron is
the only reason that I still eat blue
apron delivers form fresh ingredients
and step-by-step recipes to your door
sweet little ELISA was out of town for
about a week here she's visiting family
so she left me a tray of ziti that was
very nice you know I got to eat that if
not for blue apron I would be living in
the gutter it have nothing to eat
I'd be no lying on my own flesh let blue
apron do all the meal prep for you
dinner in as little as 20 minutes quick
and easy recipe options with insanely
delicious flavors it's real I really
highly recommend it because you get to
cook you get the experience of cooking
you get to learn something it actually
develops a skill but you get top quality
ingredients and they send you all the
different recipes so the recipes are
always changing you get to remember the
ones that you really like and all of
them are really delicious but you don't
have to go searching for this recipe and
is this gonna be good or that they're
all excellent blue apron offers a range
of recipes bursting with flavor check
out this week's menu and get your first
three meals free let me buy you food to
listen to let me help you help me help
you blue apron calm /co FFA CoV fe fe
blue apron dot-com / co FFA Co V Fe Fe
get your first three meals free blue
apron calm a better way to cook we got
some more accusations you knew they were
coming we all knew they were coming
a lady is accusing Kavanaugh of gang
rape in the 80s or whenever she doesn't
remember this has come out before this
was this is the woman represented by
Michael avenatti
which tells you everything that you need
to know about her credibility but we're
now getting to meet her in person we
finally get a TV interview from her she
sat down with MSNBC here is just a quick
clip of the accuser Julie sweat Nick
giving this interview
[Music]
yeah it's just about as credible as I
expected the the testimony to be from
Julie sweating I think we have a little
more from the interview though don't we
will fast forward to the rest of the
interview on MSNBC things that she told
us on camera that differ from her
written statement last week we've been
trying independently to reach out to
anyone who remembers attending parties
with Julie sweat Nick and Brett
Kavanaugh and we've been asking her
attorney for names so far we've not
found anyone who remembers that she's
also unclear about when she first
decided to come forward
Julie sweat Nick says she was in
Community College when she started
attending house parties that included
high schoolers you graduated in 1980
crack from high school correct from
Gaithersburg public high school so you
would have been out of high school so a
lot of people have wondered what are you
doing at a high school party if you're
already wasn't a high school party these
parties had everybody between about an
age range of 15 16 to 25 maybe even more
how did you meet Brett Kavanaugh did you
actually meet him I did actually meet
him I remember meeting him because I
remember he's got a very distinctive
face very distinctive face did you know
anything about red Cavanaugh no I just I
I believe he might have been wearing a
Georgetown Prep uniform which a lot of
the boys used to wear at least a uniform
or parts of their uniform there are some
differences between sweat and extreme
statement last week oh gee you don't say
there's some differences between your
story story is changing and she's
denying certain things she used to say I
love her answer though because obviously
this woman is I think maybe a little bit
of a kook but also clearly just a liar a
liar through through and we'll get
through her long history of lying but
she's such a bad liar so they say well
you you were already out of high school
you were in college Community College at
the time why would you go to a party
with 15 year olds I know there was
everybody there 15 16 32 47 and I don't
know any number any old number you want
say well how do you know that you you
met Rick Cavanaugh oh well you know his
that face you know that face and what's
great
about it is he doesn't have a
distinctive face he doesn't it he's God
not to insult the judge he's a handsome
enough man but he's got a very plain
face he's like kind of the cookie cutter
young Republican right he's got the hair
parted to the side and he's sort of I
don't know he's not in great shape but
he's not too completely out of shape
he's just like if you said pick just
draw me a milquetoast
judge you would just draw that guy he is
just the archetype of that so he doesn't
have a distinctive face in them well how
else do you know you met him like what
was he wearing oh it was wearing a I'm
Brett Kavanaugh t-shirt he was wearing a
yeah I remember distinctly he had this
shirt that said I'm Brett Kavanaugh
I went how do you know you met Michael
Knowles I was wearing a daily wire
t-shirt
he just wore that damn daily wire
t-shirt everywhere he went you know yeah
reminds me in norm MacDonald's book
based on a true story he says that
anywhere he goes he would wear a norm
show t-shirt and a SNL a Norma Connell
jacket something like that you know
that's the other day saying Brett
Kavanaugh did so she's also just a liar
and she's a demonstrated liar she has a
long history of making false allegations
her ex-boyfriend went on TV I won't
subject you to that interview but he
went on TV and said that she after they
broke up she threatened to fight him go
after him get violent with him litigious
whatever she also has tried to sue
everybody for harassment physical
harassment sexual whatever so she she
tried to sue American Airlines for
harassment
she made multiple unsubstantiated
workplace misconduct claims in 94 she
filed a personal injury a lawsuit
against the DC Metro I should I used to
get so angry because that metro takes
forever especially during the summer so
she filed a got some money out of it
apparently then we found out that she
lied in her claim about the lawsuit and
then she named for people to corroborate
this story that she met Brett Kavanaugh
you know with that distinctive face and
that I am Brett Kavanaugh t-shirt at
this party and so she named for people
to corroborate so the news called these
four people one of them said I
never heard of Julie sweat Nick I don't
know who that is
another one is dead and then the other
two didn't respond to requests for
comment so I think according to
Democrats that makes her absolutely
perfectly credible she must be believed
the new Saint Julie sweat neck of the
wacky eyes but I think for sane people
we know that this woman is a liar and it
brings up an important point because
what we're hearing this whole time is
why would any woman make up an
allegation like this why would any woman
lie why would any woman not know why
would any woman misremember I don't know
but look at her look at that wackadoodle
she clearly isn't telling the truth so
for perhaps a band all of the biggest
rape cases the big national rape news
stories in recent memory have been
hoaxes Tawana Brawley Duke lacrosse the
UVA so many others so okay that strategy
is failing so what's the next democratic
strategy the next strategy is he lied in
his testimony so they're saying he
perjured himself who cares if Ford has
changed her story
who cares if Julie sweat Nick is
obviously an insane person who cares
about any of those things what matters
is that when brick haven't always called
to testify he misspoke or he perjured
himself relied or whatever he hid he
actually had more beers than he said he
had all right I guess so so that's this
is their new strategy that he perjured
himself and the news media are just
lying about this they're flat-out line
first of all first of all he let's not
forget Brett Kavanaugh should never have
been in this position they never should
have allowed these hearings to happen
they should have immediately voted and
just simply confirmed him now these
hearings have been allowed to happen it
may read and two Republicans benefit
though there is some some worries still
but he never should have been in this
position if someone you know they
basically put him in out in front of the
Senate Judiciary Committee and said a
judge Kavanagh when did you stop beating
your wife I didn't beat my wife say okay
stop getting so angry senator suddenly
you're getting so angry sound like a guy
who still probably beats his wife when
did you stop I didn't stop
so you're still beater no I didn't I
never beat her stuff yelling senator so
so this is the game that there
now the question is what did it what
would he have lied about so there are
these text messages that came out NBC
News is running with this story
they said the Kavanagh lied about when
he learned of Debbie Ramirezes
allegations Debbie Ramirez is this girl
who says that Kavanaugh whipped it out
whipped out little Bret and a party
freshman year in college when they were
all very drunk
and other people who have been asked
about this say it didn't happen so I
don't know who knows it again don't know
if it's true don't know she's lying
don't know if she's misremembering don't
know if it was another guy certainly
don't care either way about something
that happened 35 years ago that nobody's
brought up until five seconds ago when
it was politically expedient but the
Cavanaugh said or what NBC is alleging
is that Cavanaugh said he didn't know
about the accusation until he read about
it in the press but bum-bum-bum these
text messages have come out of Cavanaugh
reaching out to other people asking them
if they remember this or to refute this
or to go go to bat for him and that
happened before the Ramirez story made
it into the papers so we got him he
perjured himself he's a liar if he's
lying about this he's lying about
everything
NBC kind of buried the lead though which
is that when Cavanaugh has already
testified that he heard that Debbie
Ramirez the accuser was reaching out to
other classmates asking her them to
confirm the story that she said happened
or that other people said happened and
that he heard about that but he didn't
know what the accusations were so then
he was also reaching out and saying what
happened what are you saying happened I
don't know this that the other thing so
he didn't perjure himself and NBC News
is updated this story but they won't
change the headline they won't make a
retraction they want none of that
because they always do the hit job first
and they do that on page 1a they do that
in prime time before the whole country
and then they issue the retraction or
that the correction or the slight change
on page Z 57 at 3:00 in the morning and
nobody pays any attention the great
example of this is Candy Crowley during
that 2012 presidential debate between
Mitt Romney and Barack Obama the
question was whether Barack Obama
called the Benghazi terrorist attack a
terrorist attack the day of or if he
waited to sometime and he said I did it
the day of Romney said he didn't do it
the day of candy crowley said he did do
it he called it a terrorist attack that
day governor you're wrong and then it
turns out she she was completely dead
wrong about that so after the entire
country was watching after they all
tuned out and then later on you know an
hour later she said oh yeah i got that
wrong whoops
tee-hee-hee and then so that's what NBC
is doing it with this Cavanagh thing
they do it time and time again
nevertheless didn't perjure himself the
other one they're trying to say he
perjured himself because he said that he
drank less beer than he really drank
okay all right maybe he drank a little
extra beer by the way how much beer you
drink is relative I got to tell you I've
been around even just New York and LA
nobody in LA drinks people don't drink a
lot in New York people drink like fish
by New York standards I'm a teetotaler
by LA standards I'm like the caricature
of Brett Kavanaugh you know I'm like
speaking in cursive what seems to be the
officer problem and um you know part of
that is because in LA everybody's
smoking the Haitian oregano but I am
just trying to make the point these
things you know are we really gonna sink
a Supreme Court nominee over whether he
had three or four beers I don't think so
so that line of attack I don't think
really works then they have a new one
here's the new one and this one is very
personal to me because it involves Brett
Kavanaugh when he was in college at Yale
going to a lot of bars around New Haven
I've been to just about every bar around
New Haven and he got into a major bar
fight
did you hear about that did you hear
what happened I know what you think guns
drawn knives pulled out shares getting
broken right I've actually been in bars
in New Haven at Yale affiliated events
where like 20 minutes after I leave a
gun goes off you know I mean New Haven
is not the most pleasant town in America
but no that's not what happened it's not
the cabin I was there and some guy
pulled a knife or a gun or pulled a
snoop doggy dogg and started shooting
out a car window any of that
it's the Brett Kavanaugh threw an ice
cube at some guy he that sick monster
that predator Brett Kavanaugh was have
it first of all the really crazy thing
because we know Brett Kavanaugh likes
beer is that he
had ice and his beer I think that's the
actual unforgivable thing that he did
that's the best a disqualifying activity
maybe that's how we know he didn't do it
it's cuz nobody puts their ice and their
beers but anyway the allegation is that
he was at this bar and he had a drink
and and he took some ice and he threw
ice at a guy off with his head he's out
no time for judge Barrett so that's the
allegation I don't know do you
let's we'll do a quick flash poll do you
think that throwing ice at a guy at a
college bar is disqualifying for the
Supreme Court no no I'm getting him I'm
hearing no from everybody okay so never
mind that ones up and then so now he's
still facing look he said in his
testimony this has already ruined my
reputation my family my life I mean it's
really destroyed his career there are
practical and professional consequences
to this that are already happening to
the judge and we will go into that in
just one second but first let me save
you a little money honey just in case
just in case any of these awful
professional things happen to you and
your life is destroyed you're gonna be
thankful that you save a little money
when you were online shopping honey is
the way to do it I love honey it's a
free shopping tool that automatically
searches the internet for the best promo
codes every time you buy something
online I have been using it for years
long before they were a sponsor long
before I had a show long before my black
book I especially you know when I'm was
just a broke struggling conservative out
here in Hollywood I I would use it all
the time I use it constantly honey has
already saved listeners of this podcast
in average an average of 46 eighty-nine
and I know that doesn't include me
because my numbers are way higher but
already listeners of this podcast have
Sabo almost 50 bucks using honey you
should too don't be a fool I'm giving
you free money I couldn't tell you the
last thing I bought with honey because I
buy everything with honey I buy books
with honey I've everything on Amazon I
use honey for butt but a lot of other
stuff too I watches you know all these
kind of things so it has 10 million
members over 100 thousand five star
reviews honey is the money saving
shopping tool that everyone can agree on
get honey for free it is totally free do
it right now takes two second
to add join honey calm / cough FAC o VF
e fe that's join honey calm / cough FAC
o VF e EF e honey is the easiest way to
save money while shopping on line so
judge Cavanaugh is already facing
professional consequences for this he he
was supposed to teach a course at
Harvard in the spring Harvard has fired
him from teaching the course I
technically he wrote a letter he said my
schedule will not permit it but that was
only after all of these alumni and
faculty members and students say it
would be awful if Harvard brought a
Supreme Court justice to teach at their
law school they said would be terrible
they couldn't do it because he's a
rapist because he's a rapist don't you
know I know that no one's even really
accused him of rape but he's a rapist
we'll get to that in a second his that
is so despicable I was in an event last
night and it really opened my eyes to
how the left is treating this so so he
lost his job at Harvard by the way if
they actually succeed in working him if
they actually succeed in torpedoing him
they've got to kick him off the DC
Circuit right they have to kick him off
the DC Court of Appeals how could you
have a rapist on the DC Court of Appeals
if the allegation that he's some
super-secret Nazi rapist I don't know
what the allegations are now but I you
know I assume he's a Nazi - just throw
the whole book at him if the allegation
is that he's a sexual predator and end
up maybe a murderer
according to part of Ford's testimony
then how on earth could he serve on the
second highest court in the land he has
to lose that job we should be banished
banished somewhere to the South Pacific
or something the ACLU is spending 1
million dollars to oppose Brett
Kavanaugh in in commercials that they're
already running you might be a little
confused the ACLU stands for the
American Civil Liberties Union they're
supposed to protect people's civil
liberties but the trouble is the ACLU is
a Jo ke so they're not doing that at all
they've gotten even crazier than they
used to be the whole point of the ACLU
is to protect the individual against the
mob against the lynch mob against
injustice to protect their civil
liberties nobody in recent American
history has had their civil liberties so
brazenly trampled as a judge
red Cavanaugh and what are they doing
they're jumping on the bandwagon and
destroying them even more the the ACLU
has never once opposed to judicial
nominee to mine ah I don't think it's
ever happened before
in their history and now they're coming
out they they put up this tweet with a
video the tweet said quote senators pay
attention a vote to confirm judge
Kavanagh is a vote that tells survivors
their experiences can be disregarded if
they inconvenience their powerful
abusers America is watching we will
remember so what they're saying by the
way is that Brett Kavanaugh is an abuser
the ACLU has convicted him with no
evidence with a lot of evidence that the
accusations are bogus they've convicted
him he's a sexual abuser
although these women Christine for their
victims they're survivors I mean
Christine Ford was almost killed
according to part of her testimony at
some point that she made five seconds
ago
they've already convicted him of it and
they're spending a million bucks to try
to stop Cavanaugh and they produced this
silly silly commercial my name is
Christine Blasi Ford I am here today not
because I wanted to be I am here because
I believe it is my civic duty to tell
you what happened to me
while Brett Kavanaugh and I were in high
school Meera's told The New Yorker
magazine Cavanaugh exposed himself to
her during the dorm the other major
development that third accuser now
coming forward with a sworn statement of
a fourth and fifth accused er after a
third accuser as I said came forward
earlier today the air as another woman
comes forward it is not my
responsibility to determine whether mr.
Cavanaugh does
to sit on the Supreme Court my
responsibility is to tell you the truth
with what degree of certainty
do you believe Brett Kavanaugh assaulted
100%
so the American Civil Liberties Union
has now the ACLU has become the ALM you
I think it's the American lynch mob
Union that's what it is they're the
American lynch mob Union they're
whipping people up into a lynch mob
they're defending the lynch mob they're
trying to make sure that the lynch mob
gets their guy by the way this
commercial has all the subtlety of one
of those Sarah McLachlan commercials
with a little puppies and studyin you
know I'm sorry Andrew it's like it makes
that look subtle it makes that look like
it's a really sober and serious
commercial how it so they asked the
accuser look the accuser said that that
he did it so he did it right isn't that
how it works
look hey the white woman said that that
black guy tried to rape her so get him
get him boys go get him boys the Abe
we're the ACLU go get him absolutely
despicable absolutely awful and such an
irony I mean it is worth pointing out
how we talk all the time about how
political correctness just inverts
reality so it's always the opposite it's
always an opposite day for the left you
know so social justice right is not
justice oh they're always political
correctness is not correctness they
always do the opposite it's the same
with the ACLU here they are they are
doing they are destroying civil
liberties in this country by joining the
lynch mob against Brett Kavanaugh still
I don't know if it's gonna work
you know I I was at this event last
night I was invited to be on a panel
with a bunch of lefties and it was at
the Hollywood improv and it was that you
know a couple comedians that opened it
up and then we had a political panel and
it was funny yeah there's mostly left
wingers there but there was another
conservative the comedian Michael Loftus
was very funny and so we're sitting on
the panel and it's a few comedians and
some political I was one of the
political guys and then a Democrat
political guy and I was struck that they
they almost uniformly called Kavanagh a
rapist they called him a rapist so they
referred to him as a rapist
they called him a rapist christine ford
hasn't called him a rapist
nobody others I mean this wacko that
Michael avenatti dragged up that even
NBC doesn't believe
ooh I guess she said that he was a
rapist but even actually even she says
she doesn't have any evidence of that
you didn't see him do anything but these
lefties are calling him a rapist even
though no one's even accusing them of
that even if they had you there is a
presumption of innocence but they're
doing it and it's so ugly
I mean it's so right now in Illinois at
the GOP office in Illinois a bunch of
vandals covered it in the word rape they
just wrote the word rape all over the
office is rape rape rape and it occurs
to me rapists is the new racist rapist
is the new racist they used this is what
the left used to do when they have no
argument they call you a racist
they still do this when they have no
argument they call your race a racist
now when they have no argument they call
you a rapist and it shows you a militant
they've gotten how shameless they've
gotten have despicable they've gotten
Ann Coulter told me once when I was in
college that when I left he calls you a
racist you know you've won the argument
now it's gotten so much uglier I mean
it's all it was always it used to be
that being a rape being called racist
was the worst thing you could be called
in America now they've turned it up to
11 and now it's rapists it's so awful
because we used to always say when they
would call non racist people racist we'd
say you know you're really making light
of bigotry you're really doing a
disservice to the cause of racial
tolerance and racial justice by calling
people who are not bigoted bigots but
now they're making such light of rape
that there's they're doing a huge
disservice to women who actually are
raped but they don't care they don't
care at all they don't care about women
I mean that the real hashtag is hashtag
I believe all women except when Ada
Broderick and Cara Monahan and a number
of others they don't they're so preening
about this it's so disgusting and if I
were a woman I would be furious I'd be
furious that a crime that's this I
suppose the second worst crime if not
the worst crime rape is now just some
little plaything for Democrats rapists
you're a rapist what are you talking
about don't you are you I said so you
are because I want to win this election
because Trump lowered my taxes too much
and that bothers me for some reason it's
so disco a woman I'd be so disgusted by
that and I don't
in the long run this is gonna serve
Democrats you know when they called
everybody and their mother a racist that
led to Donald Trump that led to Donald
Trump we said we're not gonna take this
anymore
like kicking over the tables you know
you don't get to tell it you don't get
to do that anymore and if they keep
doing this thing with it with rapists
which is so much more despicable I
you're not going to get that blue wave
let's put it this way and Senator
Lindsey Graham senator cocaine Lindsey
that's my new nickname for his cocaine
Lindsey he has a great strategy if if
they succeed at torpedoing the Brett
Kavanaugh nomination if he's down by you
I know he loses by one or two votes here
is Lindsey Graham's strategy what would
happen if something really weird did
occur and we're one vote short here's
what I would tell the president I would
appeal the verdict of the Senate to the
ballot box this good man should not be
destroyed if you legitimize this process
by one vote short will be unto the next
person I'd hate to be the next person
nominated I would feel horrible that we
destroyed Cavanaugh so what would I do I
would read on innate him and I would
take this case to the American people
and I'd s voters in Indiana and Missouri
and North Dakota and other places for
Trump one saying who he would nominate
if he got to be President and see if the
voters want to appeal the verdict of
their senator perfectly correct exactly
right and the Lindsey Graham is a shrewd
politician almost anybody who makes it
to the Senate with with very few
exceptions is a political genius
drew says all the time that the guys who
make it up to that level or the all-star
team I mean they are the ones who are
really really good at politics and
Lindsey Graham is one of the best of
them and not saying he's the most
conservative guy in the world that
nothing is the best philosophically
ideologically but politically he's a
really shrewd operator and he knows that
the American people want Cavanaugh
confirmed they all of the poll number
will go into the polls on this tomorrow
but all of the poll numbers are showing
this huge momentum in the direction of
confirming Brett Kavanaugh and
especially in those red states so this
gives the
Chuck Shumer Sophie's Choice this is
Sophie's Choice for Chuck Schumer he's
got to kill one of his babies which is
ironic because this whole thing is about
killing babies in the first place this
whole thing is about Roe vs. Wade and
people aren't really talking about it we
have to remind them every now and again
this whole thing is about Democrats
abortion lust it is all about Roe vs.
Wade but Chuck Schumer now has to kill
one of his babies he can either keep
fighting Cavanaugh or he can try to win
the Senate but he can't do both he can't
do both if he had torpedoed Cavanaugh if
they had gotten Cavanaugh out then it
would then it would have redounded to
his benefit then I think it would've
been a blue tornado but if you take a
shot it when the stakes are this high if
you take a shot with a supreme court
pick in this political climate with this
president and a pick that will shift the
balance of the court that will change
the dynamic the al gore search didn't
change the dynamic so Democrats didn't
play as hard this guy does he moves the
court in a more originalist more
textualist and therefore a more
conservative direction if you're gonna
take that shot you better not miss you
better hit him you better take him out
on your first shot because if it doesn't
work you are going to royally infuriate
all of those red state Democrats and
there are a number of races up now where
that could really imperil Democrats
chances there we've got all of the poll
numbers and it's it is look you know I
take polls with a grain of salt but the
movement in all of these different
states in all of these different polls
is pretty uniform and it's all happening
because of Brett Kavanaugh we'll get to
that in a second but I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we have
a lot more coming up we got to talk
about snoop diggity Doo dog who
allegedly shot a guy or was party to
shooting a guy near my old neighborhood
in LA and he is mocking and yelling at
Kanye West for being an Uncle Tom
because Kanye West thinks for himself we
will analyze that also Republicans gave
Woodrow Wilson a stroke because they
don't like globalism on this day in
history and an important poem for a
little addendum to this day in history
all of that and more but you've got to
go to daily wire.com if you go there you
get me you get the end reply be sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you ask
questions in the mailbag and especially
the conversation blah blah blah about
this is what you get oh the leftist
tears tumblr
now I'm not I'm not offering you my
current brew yet because I do want it to
age and it needs to age because what we
need is four we need four judge Kavanagh
Associate Justice Kavanagh to be that
deciding vote whenever roe v-- wade
comes up however that case is gonna be
looked at again I don't know how it's
gonna be some little baby is gonna sue
or something but however it comes up and
then when that justice Kavanagh he
remembers oh he remembers Kamala Harris
he remembers Dianne Feinstein Hyrum he
remembers that Roe vs. Wade is an absurd
decision the worst in our nation's
history and then he is going to bring
justice the likes of which we have not
seen in a long time and Feinstein is
going to go from a full human being full
of water they say our bodies are
something like 90% water she's going to
turn into a raisin and all of that water
is gonna go right into the leftist
here's tumbler you're gonna guzzle it
down it's going to be so so delicious go
to daily we're calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
delicious delicious so now the rest of
you are out you're either on daily
wire.com or you're listening on itunes
which we appreciate by the way if you
wouldn't mind please leave some
five-star reviews and subscribe on
iTunes and get all your friends to
subscribe the main reason I need you to
do this is because it really bothers
been you know whenever I get a lot of
good reviews on iTunes it really bothers
him and this brings me great joy and I
get to sort of do a little jiggle around
the daily wire offices so I'd appreciate
that if you wouldn't mind doing that
okay we've got to get into these polls
because the polls look great since this
Cavanaugh thing since they've been
targeting Cavanaugh for well for all of
those allegations where there's no
corroboration whatsoever you know the
Christine Ford thing where everybody she
names refutes her fantasy of what went
on and the obviously Michael a vanadis
kooky client to who knows what she's
thinking and then he threw ice at a guy
at a bar one time and then he apparently
had a couple beers in college and then
he who blah blah blah ever since they
did all that their poll numbers have
fallen right now
Claire McCaskill has fallen behind Josh
Hawley in Missouri a Heidi Heitkamp is
way behind in North Dakota I think she's
something like 10 points behind now
behind her Republican opponent Mike
Braun is ahead of Joe Donnelly in
Indiana just a little bit and in Montana
in Montana there's a dead heat Jon
Tester the Democrat is only up by four
points so close to her within the margin
of error but it's an a dead heat right
now wasn't supposed to turn out that way
was it I thought it was a blue wave
remember they've been saying it's a blue
wave for like 25 years now John Asaf is
gonna win in Georgia remember John a so
if nobody remembers John so but they
they are caught you know they're
constantly saying here's the blue waver
is the blue wave they're a little quiet
now aren't they why because reasonable
people don't want to see a good man
destroyed over this sick nonsense and
they don't want to see Democrats make a
mockery of rape which is what they're
doing they're making a mockery of rape
it's disgusting and they should be
ashamed of themselves so great news on
the on that front what are they going to
do is Chuck Schumer or the Democrats
going to keep going after Kavanagh are
these red state Democrats going to keep
going after Kavanagh rile up their base
and lose the red states or are they
going to drop the Cavanaugh stuff and
try to salvage those swing states I
don't know but those are the two choices
and I got to tell you something I'm not
sure that it's in the Democrats interest
to salvage the red states I'm not sure
it's in the Democrats interest to retake
the Senate why not well if they if they
can take the house which historically
they're supposed to do but I'm not even
sure that they're going to do that then
they can obstruct president Trump's
agenda to a reasonable degree and they
can impeach President Trump which they
all really want to do they've been
clamoring to do there is no situation in
2018 where the Democrats are going to
win in a enough Senate seats to convict
President Trump if Trump is impeached
he's not going to be convicted and then
what happens then you're in a then
you're in a Bill Clinton situation where
probably impeachment actually redounds
to Trump's benefit I'm giving Democrats
free advice here by the way so you guys
should I know that like two of them
watch this show so they're probably not
going to hear about this but I don't
really see the benefit of them winning
these red states because if they win
these red states it means they're gonna
have to drop all this Cavanaugh stuff
and they're gonna have to alienate
they're absolutely hysterical childish
insane base and look I'm mocking their
base but their bases their base those
are the guys that they rely on so I
don't know maybe they won't do that
maybe they won't maybe they'll they'll
say okay sorry heidi heitkamp sorry
claire mccaskill sorry Donnelly sorry
guys we're gonna double down on this and
look it they're in a bad situation the
Democrats are in a bad situation cuz
they took their shot and they missed
they meant they might still get him yet
but it's not looking great if the longer
that the at this point the longer that
this drags out without any credible
allegations and none of which have come
up yet at this point it looks like it's
going to read out to Republicans benefit
probably we should have awarded this
whole thing and just confirmed him and
then we just be running this election on
the economy and peace abroad all of
which is going very very well so I think
Republicans also would have had a real
advantage there but where we are now
maybe the Democrats just have to cut
ship and abandon their guys in those red
states and I don't know it's up to them
they're in a tough spot I don't really
care what happens because either way
things are looking up for the GOP in
other political news a white powdery
substance was sent to Ted Cruz's
campaign off
so obviously people thought it was
anthrax and some people went to the
hospital but it turns out it wasn't
anthrax I could have told them that from
the beginning because that package was
meant to go to Mitch McConnell's office
that was not intended for Ted Cruz and I
promise you it wasn't anthrax okay it's
interesting I think I met Cruz office
probably to keep the package you know I
said no no I don't know where I went I
guess we must have lost it hello no
they're not gonna do that I think he's
gonna beat Beto O'Rourke bet to robert
Francis Beto O'Rourke Michael John
McGarrett Knowles Yeah right
III really don't think our work post is
much of a challenge though it does the
polls do say it's tight and the the
cycle is so strange I guess there's a
chance he pulls it out but I wouldn't
put money on it I I do bring up I don't
just bring up the fake anthrax letter
though to make a cocaine joke about
Mitch McConnell I also bring it up
because it shows you the desperation of
these Democrats in the the depths to
which they're stooping in the Trump era
especially in this election but they've
been doing it for a long time let's be
honest about that they've been doing it
since Robert Bork at least since Ted
Kennedy played did the same exact
playbook against Robert Bork he hates
women women will die way away away and
they they shot down that nominee when
they shouldn't have and then again with
Clarence Thomas and they've been keep
trying to do it again and they it's so
disgusting but they're out for blood and
they're sending fake poison to Senate
GOP Senate Senators and Senate
candidates and what they do is they gasp
like they first they they admonish
Republicans for not being polite enough
they say you're not being polite enough
yeah send them to poison send a mad
poison that will kill all of them yeah
go a go assault them at their homes go
out where they sleep we know multiple
Democrats they go out major Democrats
and go out and attack Republicans where
they and their children sleep that we
now have this Georgetown professor
distinguished associate professor that
we talked about yesterday saying that
she wants to murder and castrate white
men that it would give her great joy
so Georgetown University finally issued
a statement about this do you know what
they said they defended the professor
they defended the professor for saying
she wants to castrate and murder
Republican white men she said but they
said she'll be fair in the
room she wouldn't be fair that you know
she does look I've been around
Georgetown there are white Republican
men in Georgetown who attend there you
really think she's gonna be fair in the
classroom are you kidding me
so they defend her and all of this
brings me back to to woke Lindsey Graham
to new Lindsey Graham I don't give a
darn I'm going out there re nominate
them that's the attitude to have because
the Republican and conservative instinct
is to be nice guys is to be civilized
fair enough we sit where we prefer
civilization we like being civilized
yeah but you you can be a brutal you can
you you can be no that's not the word
I'm looking for you can be tough and
hard and punch back really hard without
being vulgar and I think that's what
Republicans should do because
conservatives what we want to do is say
oh well I don't know well let's see if
dr. Ford's testimony is legitimate mail
let's see and maybe he doesn't remember
it oh you can't you don't want to fly
here because you have a fear of flying
even though you fly to French Polynesia
and Hawaii and New Hampshire and year
and there and there and there
okay well we'll fly out to you and they
all they do this thing no no don't they
so we have to push off the vote Oh Jeff
Flake a George Soros operative
approached me in an elevator so I can't
we have to push off the vote no you
don't know you don't you don't owe them
a single explanation you don't these
these Democrat operatives the George
Soros operatives in the elevators with
flake and the ACLU and Dianne Feinstein
and Kamala Harris
they are despicable and you don't owe
them a single explanation just hold the
vote don't you don't owe them an
explanation the American people don't
want you to give them an explanation to
give these Democrats an explanation
they're playing vicious ugly brutal
politics they want to murder and
castrate you sure a Georgetown professor
said it Georgetown University backed her
right on up Maxine Waters leading
Democrat elected official says we should
go to Republicans houses and keep their
children up at night don't play nice
with them don't play nice punch them
back rhetorically not physically very
very hard and hold votes and push right
on through don't be nice be like woke
Lindsey Graham
okay and Lindsay good job buddy let's
get into a Snoop Dogg before we have to
go here we've got a few more we got
actually a number of other things we're
gonna run late I don't care we're
running late today Snoop Dogg is calling
Kanye West and Uncle Tom they always do
this by the way the the left they call
if you're a black person who doesn't
know the party line they call you Uncle
Tom if you're a woman who doesn't owe
the party line they call you an aunt
Lydia that's the that's the lady version
of Uncle Tom I guess
and so Snoop Dogg posts a picture on his
Instagram about Kanye and he says this
quote Magga music ain't getting
attention I'm gonna have to edit this as
I go because Snoop Dogg has a limited
vocabulary and I'm not allowed to say
some of the words that he uses most
regularly but he says make you music
great again ninja Uncle Tom I'm gonna
just say ninja fella
laisse fella but that's the not the word
he said but fella I don't give a hoot if
you like that fella you mother-lovin
racist to heck you and to heck with him
now what draw the line fella Kanye to
buddy don't forget about him too to heck
with you too I think I confused that
more than I needed to I think you should
go to Instagram if you want to read the
original viewer discretion advised so
anyway you can see Snoop Dogg a really
an eloquent writer he clearly has a
mastery of the English language
very literate person and so Snoop Dogg
you might remember him for those of you
who are not familiar he is the guy who
was acquitted of murder for a drive-by
shooting in my old neighborhood in LA in
the 1990s even though the panel was
deadlocked on the charge of voluntary
manslaughter because he was totally in
that car with that guy with that gun who
shot that other guy and so what he did
this store if you don't know about this
because we think of snoop Diggy do Dawg
as some pothead who you know says mean
things about women and posts on
Instagram and his friends with Martha
Stewart or something but he in the 1990s
he drove by a gang member in the Palms
neighborhood of LA and he was there the
guy got shot after an altercation with
these guys the defense said that the
victim was reaching for his gun and so
therefore Snoop Dickie doodads buddy
pulled out his gun and shot him I don't
know just trying to paint a picture of
what kind of person Snoop Doggy dog is
so anyway why was he so upset at mr.
West
he was upset because Kanye West is no
longer a Democrat that's why that's the
whole thing
so here's what Kanye West said this is
what really irked him if Kanye West said
this on SNL he said quote 90% of news or
liberal 90% of TV la New York writers
rappers musicians so it's easy to make
it seem like it's so so so one-sided the
blacks weren't always Democrats you know
it's like the plan they did to take the
father's out of the home and put them on
welfare does anybody know about that
that's a Democratic plan which statement
do you think is more coherent which guy
do you think has a better grasp on
reality the one who said I don't give a
hoot if you like that ninja you mother
love and racist fu him now what draw the
line ninja Kanye to buddy don't you yeah
that guy or the one who just actually
explained the history of the
relationship of black voters and
Democrats but for the 20th century which
one Kanye is making perfect sense I
never thought I would say that but you
know look we got cocaine Lindsay we got
cocaine Mitch we got president PFF a
we're in a brand new age aren't we and
and Konya is making a lot of sense so
they call him an Uncle Tom that this
happens to one degree or another to a
lot of people who to quote Clarence
Thomas in any way deign to think for
themselves and refuse to kowtow to an
old order whether it be to use Thomas's
words uppity blacks or women or any
other group and subsection of the
population that the Democrats have
claimed ownership over and so you got to
stay strong I mean you know as Ann told
me when I was a wee college lad when the
Democrats call you a racist you know
you've won the argument now when the
Democrats call you a rapist you know
you've won the argument when they call
you an Uncle Tom or an aunt Lydia or
whatever other word they're going to use
hold your head up high it means you're
doing something
this brings us to this day in history we
have we got a run through these things
always art oil nature is but art unknown
to the in doll chance direction which
that cants not see so on this day in
history 1919 President Woodrow Wilson
suffered a stroke he suffered a stroke
according to the history books and
according to Wilson's widow because of
Republicans because Republicans trolled
him and too and triggered him so much
that he actually had a stroke I don't
know that this is really why he had a
stroke but in any case he had just done
this tour of the country to promote his
League of Nations because Woodrow Wilson
the imperial president decided that he
was going to govern the country like a
monarch like a dictator and he was going
to form this super national imperial
government and we were just gonna have
to go along with it because he's the man
he's Woodrow Wilson he's our leader so
he forms the League of Nations and goes
around the country to sell it and
Americans just don't want it we rejected
it because we're not going to let
ourselves be governed by some super
national body that has no allegiance to
us and we no allegiance to it and all
sing Kumbaya well they take away all of
our liberties and sovereignty so he had
this intense tour scheduled 8,000 miles
22 days he suffered all of these
headaches during the during the tour he
collapsed in Colorado and he did make it
to Washington but he suffered a
near-fatal stroke on this day in history
as wife blames the Republicans in
Congress and called it character
assassination for attacking Woodrow
Wilson we're seeing real character
assassination these days what
Republicans were doing in those days was
not character assassination they were
trying to stop the President Woodrow
Wilson from giving away their
sovereignty and giving away American
liberty and undermining the rule of law
and in the constitutional order we're
seeing a lot of these same things today
you know this election was in many ways
just like 1919 just like the Republicans
then who said no we are not giving
ourselves over to global governance and
giving away our liberties to ever
greater organizations that have no
allegiance to us and no accountability
to us the same same thing today and
we're seeing the effects of that by the
way President Trump
just renegotiated the NAFTA agreement
stock markets and all of the countries
shot right up include and including the
United States Dow gained 250 points when
it was announced the brexit happened and
what are they said that the British
economy was going to implode Europe was
going to fall apart both countries are
doing just fine the economy and in
Britain rebounded just fine they tell us
this again and again and again and yet
again and again and again we find that
the the order of independent nation
states is the greatest governing system
for our time for our air as the best one
that we've come up with so Woodrow
Wilson suffered this stroke on this day
in history but an our day in history we
we see that very idea that Woodrow
Wilson was championing is seems to have
been dealt a pretty tough blow it's
gonna come back up because bad ideas
always come back up but for now we're
seeing how great it is when you can
strike a tough blow to a bad idea also
on this day in history I should point
out just before we leave Wallace Stevens
was born a great modernist poet he's
born in 1879 the reason I bring him up
is I I just really like this guy as a
character he is a modernist for much of
his life maybe all of his life he was
sort of secular it's not like I agreed
with him on everything or even very much
there is a story though that he had a
deathbed conversion to Catholicism
some people refute this but there is a
letter about this so I don't know we'll
see maybe maybe maybe some day in heaven
will see Wallace Stevens walking around
but the reason I like him is because he
he was an artist but he worked all of
his life as an insurance executive so he
is this wonderful poet one of the great
poets of his age if not the greatest
poet of his age certainly up there top
three top four and but he was an
insurance executive he actually worked a
job and whenever people ask you know how
to get around Hollywood how do you do
this how do you work in political media
or show business or that or that I
always say you've got to work you've
just got to work you need to have a job
and just don't don't be like the
classical version of an actor or a
writer or a producer whatever and just
wait for the phone to ring you can't do
that and he didn't do that he worked
because man has made the work even in
the Garden of Eden man was made to work
so I there's this great poem that he
it's one that in high school you used to
have to memorize I memorized when I was
in high school and I don't know that you
have to anymore I don't know that high
schools even have you memorized poems
anymore but it's called the Emperor of
ice-cream it ties in a little bit with
what we were talking about yesterday
about living forever and the keys to a
happy life and what our life is like
when we come to its end it's called the
emperor of ice-cream call the roller of
big cigars
the muscular one and bid him whip in
kitchen cups concupiscent curds let the
wenches dawdle in such dress as they are
used to wear and let the boys bring
flowers in last month's newspapers let B
be finale of seem the only Emperor is
the Emperor of ice-cream take from the
dresser of a deal lacking the three
glass knobs that sheet on which she
embroidered fan tales once and spread it
so as to cover her face if her horny
feet protrude they come to show how cold
she is and dumb let the lamp afix its
beam the only Emperor is the Emperor of
ice-cream I won't even say anything
about it I'll just let that sink in I'll
be back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018